Віталій великого Віталій дяків ще
з приводу носять це інтерв'ю дойче велле
моя паша , можна буде і трухан хату
диван їм голови повстання було в Росії
не раз були в Росії ми станемо зазвучав
я в Росію часто
безготівкову працюю я не мая можливості
виїжджати через мої щоки його і рубатися
досить рідкісне повстання бум в Росії
поєдинком у брата допомагав володіти
c був поєдинок у 2012 роті проти
Олександра Повєткіна Ксандра Повєткіна
чому заразні їзди the crypto ви ще
зайняті крім зайнятий але по польщі можна
ввести таку на травень але й вимагатимеш купа
в росію money багата друзі але
ролі чим велика кількість друзів навіть
родичі у вас є якесь особисте
а у вас є особливий станніс прийняти a
russian у зав'язку спали таку кремля
сюди україни я мою нам возіть ще shb
частини num1 руси і заразом заплутування ми
Петро янович окрім і пит вимагати ту
політику як у кремля проводити ще до
україни та підтримують політику яка
кремль проводять щось щодо україни я
не маю можливості
я не мая можливості but i в Росії і
прямо ось цю інформацію chuwi чого ти
нас троє людей я зіткнешся титів шкода
досить часто з моїми друзями на годину
тихіше і може й витягну російські канали
і може і шишку 2 ти зараховано устілки
обдуві не люди живуть у тему вакуумі
інформативним його крім я ось йому
інформацію тут ми з російським каналом
і можна сказати ще на крайніх традиціях
з в'язниці традиційне переплюнув і
Росія пропаганда і d промивання миски в
на краєчок традиціях як же кл його там
є добра у нас залишився заходу сонця
тисячі видуває в Україні інформація
не об'єктивно не 1001 gift іванівна
виклеювала нас це стосується заходу це
стосується всі диски які відбувається
спеціально з партнерами ви знаєте c
королівство кривих дзеркал на спеціально
спотворена це знати і царство кривих
дзеркал я правильно розумію, що ви
вважаєте що
я правильно розумію на вашу думку
russia map обдурити та праворуч у тому ще
москві та доступу альтернативних jira
line формації до тіла години в Росії єни
за лижні змій
проте ціни підриваючи на храм пекельну донку
проблем але проте волає 3 мкаде та росії
ще до України і в Москві, і в регіонах
Росії на Україні і в Москві і в Україні
регіонах
я картинам їду росія на добрі ставлю
сам іди і криві ства російської
федерації про зовнішню та внутрішню
П'яний політиці можна поділитися своєю
зовнішньої політики у тому числі внутрішньої
політики я не можу розділяти більше
побачиш цього я в край негативну ставлю
цю їх убогість україни менша за межу
ставлення до України та тих дій
які до інших країн мені це
нагадування ціна року я б хто дається
Очевидно не європейський союз
інформації абсолютно викроюємо саме в
абсолютної скріплена я виріс сім'ї
офіцера комуніст
я варіс рівень офіцера комуніста люди
на що приділяла через пів року і начебто
не погляди
я не був комуністом чи я б у горди за
свій українцям я не був комуністом за
комуністичну партію натомість ідеологію та
повністю був прикутий управа не
steady
і повністю був переконаний у правильності
дій я пам'ятаю
десь тато не пом'ятий цю пропаганду я
до пана вала наших головах суднозаходів
ти де і ківі збувалося і ми і
колосальний здування cool і я в репі
часто рибу вдови мама славі stick
спортсмени ви їх від і до західної Європи
і до США хоч і західну Європу і
виїхати з'єднані штати Америки на ми
немов мої слова бочками побачивши що це
спеціально дробовими місця
зроблені для тури стилі частини які
міста на візит візиту туристів все
шляхом їх арештовують і х мотаю
пропаганди показує та sin x та добрих я
бачу я бачу піди шукай сьогодні видуваються
в Росії іван і на році темряві не проти
їх холодної війни q любовний досвідчений за
зовнішньої злодій акули показував осі всіх
упири джон ще до заходу і зник його
лося всі свої
видно упереджено відношенні
заходу та проводити пропаганду лось все
свого роду
осі sage конфлікт висновок що чия прибула
конфлікт між росіян це українцям і
вин майка спить ґрунті взутися штучно
сторони конфлікт фібру типу різьблених
ідеологій імперської ідеології то
ідеології вигляд критий вірш ідеологією
імперської ідеології та ідеології а
відкритість люди кому
і людям яким душами належить обожнення
українців but i на за хибними і сама
стінами повинен і личить і обожнення
українців як частину іншу європейського
простору
ніби європейську та демократичну
україну та
і люду докази х у голові
їй так я видно ви мене будемо вид-во
засланні імперії Російської імперії
російське світло змінилося і годинник імперії
вид ходу туману за часів імперії
йдуть у минуле а взагалі роду чаю
друзі зроблять путіна росія не дуже
обережні росіян і тут же прибираєш
доставлятися до суджа
яцевич ивою багатів я відчуваю дуже
багатьох пам'ятайте такий по метає такий
плакат гумку і що при теслі смугу
губ і на опосум на базі кай пальцем на
ту не говори
ось саме про ситця та плаката за
рівненських частини впочин основа
земля-то себе шкіра там ще зависла вам
може здорово око шпинат і шкірного хто
дозволяючи собі свобода до судів не особливо
його сюди корінні 100 партії тадіч
європейський годинник і кремезний
російської федерації сьогодні та
керівництва Російської Федерації сьогодні
вони не бояться злом і спинку вати
вона не боятися або року знайомих
прагнуть би мені скаже що телефоном
ми не хочемо
літнього в особливій розмові ми зможемо
розповісти з чим думаємо чи не дозволяється
by завів а вам дістається години така
різниця між українцями та русіянова
росіянами та українцями саме
ідеологічна різниця все-таки їду
логічно вії у Росії зав ти стріляв
з оперети іржаву завжди
чекав і засланні держави було
сакралізація влади в Україні такого не
було обидва я з'являюсь а че
ідеологічний конфлікт abovyan штучно
створа на цьому ще в Росії ефективна
процес я пропагандистської машини просто
тому що в Росії
ефективно працює пропагандистська
машина в Росії ефективно працює
дуже ефективно працює в Росії дуже
ефективно проти її пропагандистської
машина він та інвестицій мільярди
доларів на всі канали код на поверх та
хвалебні мелодія з диваків ревнивого
вкрай почути мелодію в лапках
хвалебну мелодію щодо політики
керівництва країни є телебачення радіо
газети чи чині радіо газети
грають я про шрек 101 тональність он
ту тональність
то люди c називається промивання міс
іден часто думав це промивання мозку
можна з правді все так і корисними
шануєш каже і боячись нього ти раз
побачити
я ставлю собі питання я перебуваю у до
ревності україни я ніколи не був
радикалом
я не можеш апріорі на любить у росіян я
не можу я на половину росіян
моя мама знову з близько росіянка я
наполовину русский моя мама з конфліт як
мильно бульбаш копита не тільки годину
біля нього на узі
насправді цей конфлікт як мильний
міхур просто до часу коли він
лусне
вас не ображає вас не загрозливо у Росії
організує вас яка дати їм залишайтеся
девід з і сюжети про себе дивіться
сюжет про себе ви знаєте це все ви
знаєте cfc спеціального дзвони кульовими
мови мовила низу ні зги на вид на знаючи
іншого місто і є різанини ролику ми
так їх показу ти в основному фарбуємо
switel від вас, а не найкращому світлі
мета сьогодні їм це пропагандистська
машини
близько до цього ти не скошена показати
абсурдність і без голки тут у всіх тих
людей знаходиться в крем'янисті україни
всіх тих людей, які знаходяться в
керівництві ви є skoda серце нас
прямо це через я не винаходжу націю
богам я не знаю про що ви в гори хочу
про таїсію комбінації кисть ви разу і
так далі років дати йому ставлю системну
ділянці іронії та як дублювання ви вже
більше руку прайсу це на посаді мера
києва це ваша головна доставлені дня і
голови та місця та як політика
голови міста і яка ваша головна
досягнення як політика
рік тому ми приїхали до того я у ранку
серпня в закриємо втомимося і знаєш що
всі реформи всієї зміни в краю не
підкоряються за велику по воді до одеси
львова полтави та серце країни
screen цьому взявши мету складний регіон
особливо знаю чащобе дні газу лежить
подалі частка україною, а що від нього
залежить подальша доля України
за цей рік я можу сказати незважаючи на
ції рік названа ю чена тобто. у ВВП
україни впав на 10 сотки ми змогли
втекти і над ходом не до бюджету місця
на 32 сотки надходження до бюджету міста
на 30 відсотків як за рахунок ніж
просто просто ми зруйнували налог
не ми зривали корупцію в ручищі
завершувалась і в кеші них і прилипали
друг сьогодні не відходить і бюджету і
всі кульки мк айсберга як елементарно
надоєм у червоних
груп тобі вийти світла корупція
процвітає 5 хв і від любите ви немов у
офісі а сумую люблять і шум ми відкрили
мерії ми відкрили комісії ми відкрили
документа відпочинку та відкрила бюджет
місця намистин відхід женя і ви тратою
сьогодні про зорі шкіра назад і вести в
кожному журналісту можна подивитись ми
проти нього про зору прозорець 9 місці
відкрити з нею ключовим аргументом і
протікання родичам від ключових аргументів
проти корупції головне досягнення
до сильно не боротьба з
корупцією у овалом на них дача
досягнення досягнення боротьби з
корупцією на ньому, а боротьбу з корупцією
і поки що рано називати
ми спочив зради і сьогодні на виступі
модус reebok від погроз я ще без мінету
інфраструктуру ремонту йому на вулицях та
дорогий і буду йому мости, але допомагаємо і
люди міккі стояти на мисі виживання ціни
можна презентувати агресивними
c ключовик рок гра the sign вони будуть у
декади наші місця стану європейським це
не можна презентувати як досягнення це
ключові кроки які досягнення
досягнення коли можна говорити
зробимо наше місто європейським одне можу
сказати я люблю 1 можна сказати ей я
люблю київ я буду багатьох місцях змитий
уран їм чогось такого місця за своєю красою
потенціалом німаїв світлі c туристична
Мекка з культурного центру та за фінансовий
центр цін індустріальний центр
бабкіна повністю реалізувати цієї
потенціал та київ нашому місяці
реалізувати той потенціал, який є
нашому місті з 25 жовтня приплив і прямо
авіас одержання з москвою т.п. росіянам
по стежці тадук і його дістати складно
випить прийму це таке рішення при
бажанні зображення на поїзді можна до
їх через сестри в ранців ніби в
києві чи можна стаття з пересадками
з пересадками впав на ще за зради
струму ці курсу проводити російська
держава всі дані всі крима проводить
Російська федерація щодо
анексії крима повернення
вірно не території грипу мене
фінансово не провини на сході україни я
цілком і трохи з цього батько може
зміниться кардинально може змінитися
кардинально
вам здається за почати інвестиції в її
складно привабливий Стів вже складні
перрі беру участь складно зал навчають
інвестиції вже всіма деві мису телевізор
і у багатих ось така картинка ще
відриваєте скронь ідеї
приїжджають приїжджають сюди і бачать щуки в
Безтурботне місце не моя деякий час і думав
виявить і інші бізнес на місце вати в
крайність protect частування олени садиш
на них ми і змогли за промені ти фанат
апертура мільярда гривень геїв тарик а
більше півтора мільярда гривень лише
лише місто київ за минулий рік
є критики я тих хто критикуючи вас я
одному gliddery у протесті щоб
радувати ідеали євромайдану, щоб може
вона щось сказати
утворено таку думку вікового буду
там етап це ти дається прочитала вигляд
побачу в інтернеті де я потім
прочитала відповідай в інтернеті є
гарні хороший постріл читають і
наявність радянське газет ціна радіанс
kitazato спеціально заохочуйте інформації
інформація
я маніпуляції ківи хрестову ти просто
є не настрій
не діють вони використовують протесту
настрій ми українці європейці
історизми українці європейці бурхливо
історичну графічну культуру на
ментальному і європа та типу ви не
реалізувати і всі ті принципи та кинути
європейських краях і побудувати вати
демократично україну
c ключове завдання на дикі утворюю
сьогодні я до мер столиці як мер євродім
розвивати своїх принципі та вікі я принц
повинні декор вал я на вигляд шкіри я не
відходжу ви вич його це розчарування
адже українців чого це ще ваш обід
ринку змішуєте всього ваша підтримка
знижується
дисит на весь але був і блоки а чикаго
небагато чого зміниться зміниться
багато реформ реформи буксують
і в тему ключі на рік і ви з ними
врахування душі шмотки змі існують
очікуванні дуже швидких змін я
завжди говорив я завжди говори в шпигуни
борються на ти нас крикет епатажний але
адже їх чого ти став би або міази і ти
чемпіон свинтус боксу та 2 метри на зорі
100 теодена нічого не можеш труби все
завдання всіх людей готових та підключить
на увазі ті кому це завдання для всіх і
я вчу куди помел і вид шкірного миша
consist вулиці
або байдуже ярлика кілька секс
партії вікі
нічого ні рубля не опише блозі включати
аналітик прихована крутити владу
роблять аналітику критикують владу
сахіба погано з одного боку це добре
задок прибирання c добрий cool іван та
відмовляла водними підказками івашку
змінити демократія на себе взяли за
далечінь нести я не боюся в результаті
дальністю і розрухову над їхніми людьми і
такого шахти мені починають зимін колу та
місіс принесуть обруч учасниці процес
вони ніколи їм щось принесуть так само
беруть участь цих процесів як
складаються ваші 100 сумка з
президентом України петром порошенком у
нас роботі відносини у нас робоче вино
самим я розумію як світ став і ціни
маїчі петрі mkii трояндами не в
адміністрації президента ур ідея
верховній раді нам буду його шкура ліза
вата реформи і провести зради в краї
чи нам важко буде реалізувати
реформи і зробити зміну в країні я
правильно я правильно разу не ще мер
місця батька чоловіка ваших політичних
амбіцій оборони простягаються частки оксиду
чи
то роки багато хто говорить
багатий товаришам і вас посадили в
крісло мера але не потрібне крісло мера
г нам жити і все добрі може ви будете
україні і буде кому місці, де прийшов
пшона все по саду я залишу собі завдання
зайняті позицію зайняти позицію я наставлю
собі завдання за роботу вантажник
я заруби в спорті імена і все можна вас
лежить і бутіки краю на все життя алло я
хочу ж ти
усипано бочки в читанні до будинків за нормаллю
за нормальних стандартів у жити оброки я
знаю зі 100 років живий на заході мені меч
і не отримані штати я знаю ці
стандарти може ніби їм не view
йогор на при сливі обходиться хочемо
зробити добре хочеш труби це добрий
зруби сам і тому це мій сьогодні
прибувають у тих мер
я взяв на себе і повідали зграї раблі все
готові щоб я допомігш вишити зради
вигляд був ти розумний і на батьківщині там
їжте я хочу жити і в тему місці в
європейському місці в європейському краї
хочу жити у європейському місті
європейській країні можна ж можна ж
ніби президентом це ж змію в Україні
впізнаватись шульга навіть цій легше я ще
раз я говорю про процес зміни україни
починаючи склеюємо і по ви не показати
її акції заміни починають повинні показати
як ці зміни починаються ось ви
сказали, що висловив ще в мені потрібно
за рубля до вантажник би ви вже все
зарубав і як ваша зарплатня мод чи а я
зарплату на у трюми рогун дак я як мер
не отримали камер на ранкову зарплату
зачепивши таро руку я на ранковому об ні
копійки я просив і на гурманські засідки
зарплату ми не можемо це 300 було риф у
гру малінді я прийшов в українську
політику на і за рублі довше за всю свою
зарплату депутати верховної ради я
пророку мухаммаду тебе що будемо всю свою
турбот тут я на ранок мою зарплату
я просив повік волонтери і рублю цахіра
привіт серце
заробітній платі я працюю як волонтер
і роблю це щиро від серця
який вам і удачі спосіб вам